merci beaucoup d'être avec nous pendant
cette première demi-heure vous êtes
sénatrice socialiste vous représentez
les Français établis hors de France on
va bien sûr parler de la situation
internationale dans quelques instants de
l'Ukraine de l'Afrique mais d'abord la
réforme des retraites et on l'a vu
samedi environ 1 million de personnes
qui ont manifesté ce week-end selon les
chiffres de la police est-ce que vous
êtes déçu vous attendiez à plus non je
pense que sincèrement c'est un chiffre
impressionnant qui devrait impressionner
le gouvernement qui semble continuer à
ne pas écouter la rue ne pas écouter non
plus ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
nationale
et ce qui se passera au Sénat j'espère
que en tout cas nous travaillons
aujourd'hui de façon très sérieuse
préparation vraiment minutieuse d'un
texte incroyablement technique mais qui
sur le plan politique bien sûr
aujourd'hui je crois crée beaucoup de
d'inquiétudes et il serait bon que le
gouvernement entendent enfin à la fois
la rue et le Parlement c'est vrai que
pendant le premier quinquennat le
gouvernement a été habitué à ce que
l'Assemblée nationale soit une chambre
d'enregistrement le Sénat continue à
finalement exercer son rôle à la fois de
critique et puis de contrôle de son
action mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous
arrivons à un moment crucial ou nous
avons là une réforme finalement qui est
le dernier élément de l'héritage que
nous avons depuis la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale à savoir une solidarité
nationale en matière de santé
d'éducation et de retraite et là c'est
le dernier élément qu'on les Français
ont l'impression qu'on nous retire et
qu'on va abîmer mais est-ce que quand
vous entendez les syndicats qui disent
menacés de mettre la France à l'arrêt si
le gouvernement ne les entend pas vous
les entendez vous les soutenez c'est
syndicats on peut avoir une France à
l'arrêt
oui parce pour vous c'est devenu la
seule solution si le gouvernement
montrait quelques signes d'écoute
et de dialogue le dialogue ce n'est pas
simplement de la pédagogie avec des
éléments de langage qui sont donnés à
tous les membres de la majorité
présidentielle qui répètent à l'envie la
même chose ou de la com dialogue social
c'est vraiment entendre la position de
l'autre et essayer de voir comment on
peut modifier la sienne alors on ne
demande pas au gouvernement de revenir
absolument sur tout il y a des éléments
qui sont positifs dans ce qui est
présenté dans cette réforme donc gardons
les construisons dessus mais ce qui est
rejeté par la majorité aujourd'hui des
Français il serait bon que le
gouvernement est bien revienne dessus
lesquels quels sont pour vous les ce qui
vient de l'âge que vous souhaitez garder
non mais qu'est-ce que vous vous dites
il y a des éléments positifs lesquels
sont positifs qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez garder qu'est-ce que vous
allez voter dans cette réforme alors
d'abord nous devons voir
de la réforme et je crois que finalement
l'âge est vraiment l'élément de blocage
qui soutenait en tout cas le report de
l'âge qu'après il allait faire des des
propositions sur la pension de réversion
pour les enfants handicapés sur les
régimes spéciaux sur les femmes
notamment mais sur l'âge il soutient
comment vous allez peser vous ici au
Sénat est-ce que vous allez être
stratégie est-ce que vous allez dans une
stratégie d'obstruction comme l'ont été
la France insoumise comme le son les
députés de la France insoumise non c'est
pas la façon de travailler au Sénat je
crois que nous n'allons pas absolument
pas dans cette dans cette voie je crois
qu'il y aura
un vrai débat de fond et je crois qu'il
est nécessaire parce que le public les
Français attendent cela aujourd'hui ils
ont envie de savoir exactement ce qu'on
leur propose ils ont envie finalement de
d'un gage de progrès social et non pas
et c'est là et c'est peut-être pour cela
que l'on voit autant de jeunes
aujourd'hui manifestés finalement de de
blocage et de dire que on leur donne
aucune aucun espoir il y a pas d'espoir
de progrès aujourd'hui un mot pour
terminer là-dessus sur les Français de
l'étranger est-ce que ce sont les grands
oubliés du texte la manière dont
fonctionne le régime de retraite pour
les Français de l'étranger qui n'est
évidemment pas la même du coup oui
absolument sur les mais vous savez nous
sommes habitués et puisque c'est un
petit peu les personnes hors-sol bien
sûr vous allez faire des propositions
là-dessus oui mais nous sommes nous dans
la catégorie plutôt des carrières vous
savez qui ne sont pas continue carrière
haché donc nous retrouvons dans la
catégorie finalement des femmes qui ont
été présentées dans un premier temps
comme étant les grands bénéficiaires et
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
c'était un gros mensonge et c'est ce qui
agace aussi les gens et c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'ils sont aussi nombreux dans
la rue mais du coup vous allez faire des
propositions pour les Français de
l'étranger pour nous allons faire le
pris en compte bien sûr il y a un
problème de prise en compte
c'est très compliqué on ne va pas
rentrer je vous disais que c'était un
texte très technique en fait les
Français de l'étranger sont
qui d'abord peuvent travailler dans
différents pays doivent récupérer
l'ensemble de leurs cotisations dans
différentes caisses de retraite ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui les
Français de France évidemment l'examen
de ce texte ça sera dans deux semaines
au Sénas ça arrive à partir de la
semaine du 27 février en commission volo
dimirzelinski on va parler de l'Ukraine
était en tournée européenne en fin de
semaine dernière il est allé à Bruxelles
à Paris à Londres qu'avez-vous pensé de
cette tournée il a eu raison
ah bien sûr qu'il a raison en fin de
cette un chef de l'État même s'il se
présente plutôt en chef d'air il ne se
départit pas de son costume guerrier
mais bien sûr qu'il a raison son
territoire est a été envahi aujourd'hui
il a besoin d'aide pour pouvoir résister
procéder à des contre-offensives pour
récupérer finalement les bouts de
territoire aujourd'hui qui ont été
envahies par des Russes et donc il a
besoin de l'aide des pays européens
parce que vous l'avez entendu il a
redemandé des avions est-ce qu'il faut
lui envoyer des avions est-ce qu'on doit
fournir des avions en Ukraine
aujourd'hui c'est un sujet très délicat
vous avez vu quand même qu'il n'y a pas
un empressement d'aucun pays finalement
de fournir ce genre de matériel je crois
que la
la résistance vient du fait que les pays
européens ne veulent pas d'un engrenage
ne veulent pas d'une escalade et ne
veulent surtout pas que finalement les
territoires russes soient touchés à un
moment ou un autre par accident par
erreur et que l'on se retrouve
finalement avec une excuse qui soit
donnée à la Russie pour élargir le
conflit je crois que ce n'est pas dans
l'intérêt des pays européens de se
retrouver pris finalement et et
aller au delà de ce qu'il souhaite faire
c'est à dire soutenir l'Ukraine pour
arriver à un point de négociation parce
que il n'y aura jamais d'écrasement
total ni de l'Ukraine ni de la Russie
donc à un moment il y aura bien une
négociation politique et c'est là que
nous devons aller avec une Ukraine qui
soit la plus forte possible pour arriver
à la table des négociations et pouvoir
résister à
forte si elle n'a pas le si on ne
fournit pas le matériel qu'elle demande
Emmanuel Macron il est encore resté flou
il dit rien n'est exclu je sais pas
s'ils vont envoyer pas en envoyer vous
comprenez cette forme dans des moments
parce que la France continue à croire et
là c'est au crédit il faut le mettre
cela au crédit du président de la
République à la diplomatie à savoir que
à un moment il faudra bien que les deux
parties se parlent et arrivent à une
négociation donc nous gagnons également
du temps avec une un peu plus craignant
qui résiste de façon absolument
incroyable une montre une résilience
extraordinaire et puis des matériels
également qui a eu mais vous savez on ne
forme pas non plus un pilote en quelques
semaines on forme pour les matériels
terrestres en quelques mois mais les
pilotes ça demande deux ou trois ans de
formation donc même si on devait fournir
des pilotes des des avions faudrait bien
mettre des pilotes dedans donc ça serait
dans trois ans ou plutôt vendredi vous
allez participer à la conférence de
Munich sur la sécurité vous serez l'une
des rares françaises quel est l'objectif
et bien de faire entendre la voix de la
France nous avons là un rassemblement
mondial tout le monde est là les grands
acteurs nous avons de grandes
délégations qui viennent des États-Unis
du Canada un petit peu de partout enfin
des Occidentaux j'entends et donc il est
important
pour quelqu'un comme moi qui défend la
défense européenne
aujourd'hui dans dans finalement un
paysage qui est dominé par l'OTAN en
tout cas pour notre continent de se dire
que nous avons en vocation à continuer à
travailler à cette défense européenne et
que l'on voit bien avec la guerre en
Ukraine et bien que nous avons besoin
d'une base de défense et d'industrie
européenne et c'est une je crois une
voix un petit peu dissonante par rapport
à la majorité aujourd'hui qui est quand
même dans une logique très
transatlantique très hautagnienne je le
suis également mais
on va dire voilà
pas continuer de parler de là aussi
parce qu'il y a pas qu'on Ukraine que la
Russie veut étendre son influence les
Russes tentent des temps également leur
influence en Afrique au moment où les
troupes françaises connaissent des
difficultés voire du rejet on va faire
le point avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alexa
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane bonjour Hélène
le ministre des Affaires étrangères
russes Sergueï lavrof a réalisé une
grande tournée dans peser dans plusieurs
pays africains pour essayer d'étendre
l'influence de la Russie en Afrique a
été reçu la semaine dernière en grande
pompe dans plusieurs États africains
dont certains sont des amis de la Russie
il est d'abord allé en Afrique du Sud en
eswatini c'est le
l'exoisyland il est également allé en
Angola en Érythrée au Soudan et puis il
s'est rendu dans des pays où la France
avait ou a encore une certaine affluence
influence pardon comme le Maroc la
Mauritanie et le Mali c'est surtout le
Mali qui nous intéresse puisque l'armée
française a quitté le Mali en 2022 après
avoir combattu pendant 8 ans le
djihadisme sur le sol malien c'était
l'opération barkhane mais un coup d'État
militaire au Mali a changé la donne et
la gente malienne actuellement au
pouvoir s'est rapproché de la Russie
pour combattre le terrorisme les Russes
qui fournissent aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
au malien des avions de combat des armes
des missiles et puis aussi des hommes
alors même si Moscou et Bamako le nid
actuellement il y a 2000 mercenaires de
la ministre russe Wagner sur le
territoire malien pour combattre les
djihadistes la Russie qui ne se prive
pas non plus de faire de la propagande
antioxydale et anti-française écoutez ce
que disait Sergueï lavant la semaine
dernière dans sa conférence de presse
avec son homologue malien
ainsi que l'écrasante majorité des
autres pays africains considérant qu'il
est nécessaire d'oublier cette approche
de l'Afrique comme une métropole
coloniale
vu comment les Occidentaux ont annexé et
exploité ces territoires ce continent
il devrait s'habituer au fait que le
monde a changé c'est un mot
l'intention russe de décrédibiliser les
Occidentaux et la France vis-à-vis de
l'opinion africaine d'autant que cette
nouvelle coopération de l'armée malienne
et de la milice russe Wagner et très
critiquée elle est accusée de commettre
des exactions sur le terrain des
meurtres de civil des viols des pillages
de village écouter ce que répond le
ministre malien des Affaires étrangères
pour lui c'est de la pure manipulation
malheureusement
on a toujours accusé les violations des
droits de l'homme de ses souvent pas de
groupe terroristes qui eux-mêmes se
transforment en témoin pour accuser
l'état nous savons que les droits de
l'homme sont aujourd'hui
instrumentalisés politisés pour des
agents cachés à peine caché
qui vit souvent à renverser les régimes
pour pouvoir atteindre un certain nombre
d'objectifs c'est sur nous le savons
nous travaillons avec la Russie pour
pouvoir dépolitiser la question des
droits de l'homme donc la gente malienne
qui est actuellement sous influence
russe on voit avec ce type de propos la
Russie qui veut étendre son influence
au-delà du Mali et dans cette région et
elle propose de fournir des armes pour
lutter contre le djihadisme dans la
région du Sahel également à des pays du
Golfe de Guinée et puis plus étroitement
avec trois pays elle souhaite coopérer
sergueil la brosse a annoncé avec la
Guinée le Tchad et le Burkina Faso le
Burkina Faso qui est actuellement dans
la même situation que le Mali il y a eu
un coup d'État militaire et la jante au
pouvoir à sommer les soldats français
qui sont présents il y a trois semaines
de quitter le territoire
burkinabé alors notez pour finir que
cette grande tournée africaine de
sergueil Labruffe et bien elle vise à
préparer un sommet Russie Afrique qui
aura lieu à Saint-Pétersbourg cet été
Hélène connu à Mouret vous êtes
récemment dép beaucoup en Afrique dans
le cadre de vos fonctions qu'est-ce
qu'on vous dit sur cette nouvelle
influence russe est-ce que ça inquiète
sur le terrain
d'abord et pas tout à fait nouvelle
la Russie comme la Chine sont présents
depuis assez longtemps notamment par le
biais de d'accord bilatéraux en matière
de défense fourniture d'armement et et
aussi formation de personnel militaires
ce que nous faisons également donc il y
a pas de nouveautés la nouveauté c'est
que aujourd'hui nous l'entendons dans
les mots très pertinents utilisés par le
par le ministre
finalement à parler de ce que qui est
complètement en phase avec ce que les
Africains attendent c'est-à-dire le
rappel de la colonisation parce qu'il
est très facile d'avoir un bouc
émissaire quand les choses ne vont pas
bien il faut un coupable et le coupable
s'il est extérieur quand même ça aide un
petit peu le pouvoir en place de se dire
que ce n'est pas de sa faute mais de
celui qui est venu de l'extérieur très
bien et ensuite de c'est vrai que nous
avons aujourd'hui
là j'ai un terme que j'ai retenu la
dépolidisation des droits de l'homme bon
l'Europe continue à porter un certain
nombre de valeurs et à les défendre et
donc nous insistons par exemple quand
nous répondons à un appel d'offres qu'il
y ait le droit du travail qui soit
respecté les normes climatiques qui
soient respectées nous avons aujourd'hui
des entreprises russes et chinoises qui
font fi de tout cela et finalement nous
sommes en porte-à-faux par rapport à ce
que nous souhaitons de ce que nous
voulons de ce que nous défendons et de
ce que certains autres pays qui sont
également présents finalement n'en ne
nuit pas les africains avec ces sujets
là la corruption est de mise et les
acceptée acceptable
les normes internationales
sont également mises de côté alors que
nous insistons pour qu'elle soit
respectée donc voyez nous sommes en
porte-à-faux c'est vrai que le monde a
le monde a changé le monde a changé et
peut-être que nous ne sommes pas
complètement en phase et c'est vrai pour
les réseaux sociaux avec une
communication
finalement qui présente ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui on voit bien que
l'Agence française de développement par
exemple change sa communication quand
elle construit une quinzaine d'écoles
personne ne le sait il suffit que que la
Turquie ou la Chine construisent une
école pour que tous les médias
nationaux s'en félicitent donc oui nous
avons besoin de changer nous avons
besoin de changer radicalement à la fois
sur notre présence qui ne doit plus être
militaire mais qui doit être civile avec
une aide et un vocabulaire différent on
doit parler aujourd'hui de partenariat
et s'éloigner en effet de ce passé qui
continue à finalement à nous à nous
coller à la peau être un vrai boulet de
communication est-ce que la France est
dépassée face à la propagande russe qui
monte un peu les opinions africaines
contre l'armée française oui et qui
marche très très bien on le voit chez
les femmes mais bien sûr puisque ce sont
les réseaux sociaux qui sont pénétrés de
ce complotisme vous avez entendu quand
même dans les mots de
responsable malien
et nous nous sommes avec des communiqués
de presse une sorte de formation
information formelle que personne
n'écoute aujourd'hui les jeunes
sénégalais
Ivoiriens burkinabés sont sur leur
téléphone portable
et sont très sensibles à ce qui est
partagé sur les réseaux sociaux
est presque qui va sortir une semaine ou
deux semaines après pour nier un fait
alors que s'il était sorti immédiatement
avec la vérité peut-être mais ça veut
dire qu'on se trompe de stratégie ou
qu'on est trop passif face à ce qui est
en train de faire la réussite on n'est
pas en phase avec un monde qui change
très vite et on voit sur la bonne
stratégie le ministère des Affaires
étrangères aujourd'hui a une
porte-parole vous avez vu c'est assez
nouveau et cela fait plus de de deux ans
que j'envoie des notes un petit peu à
tout le monde faut leur dire mais voilà
ce que je vois sur le terrain une
jeunesse qui est en train de basculer
qui n'est plus francophone et
certainement plus francophiles ça c'est
certain dans des pays où aujourd'hui
nous pensons que parce que nous avons ce
passé en commun que forcément ils vont
continuer à nous aimer vous avez pas le
cas étrangères oui bah écoutez la mise
en place de cette porte-parole et puis
nous avons aujourd'hui également des
ambassadeurs qui sont dans la réactivité
instantanée pour en effet essayer de
contrer certaines rumeurs qui sont
lancées pour conclure vous le disiez à
la présence française en Afrique doit
devenir civile et non plus militaire ça
veut dire que nos opérations militaires
ont été un échec face au djihadisme non
elles n'ont pas été un échec les
militaires ont fait ce qu'on leur a
demandé bien est-ce qu'il fallait rester
8 ans dans un camp à Gao certainement
pas je crois que nous sommes restés plus
longtemps rappelez-vous au Sénat nous
avons demandé il y a déjà deux ou trois
ans de cela un débat sur barkhane sur
l'avenir de barkham parce que nous
avions tous les signaux que ça ne se
passait pas bien et que c'était plus
forcément la présence dont nous avions
besoin mais il faut que nous ayons une
présence militaire là où les Africains
la souhaitent en appui de ce qu'il
souhaite faire en réponse à leurs
besoins et non pas simplement de décider
que nous avons un camp et que nous
allons procéder à des frappes et à des
voilà qui ne sont pas en phase avec ce
qui est souhaité et voulu sur le terrain
par les autorités en place merci Alex à
tout à l'heure on parlera réforme des
retraites pour la deuxième semaine et
sans grande surprise dans le club on va
parler de Robert hébra pour terminer
Hélène Conway Murray c'était le dernier
rescapé du Massac de radio sur Glane en
juin 44 il est décédé ce weekend à l'âge
de 97 ans et on va aller au Diane
justement à Limoges on retrouve
Anne-Sophie pdgers bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos rédactrice en
chef adjointe du populaire du centre et
vous revenez aujourd'hui encore sur la
disparition de Robert et bras avec
notamment l'interview de l'ancien
président de la République François
Hollande
oui tout à fait bonjour à toutes et à
tous effectivement Robert Hebra s'était
éteint samedi voilà il avait mis des
années à parler de ce Massac il avait 19
ans quand il a vécu les horreurs et je
m'interrogeais je vous entendais parler
du du Mali de l'Ukraine sur ce sur ce
devoir nécessaire de mémoire comment
est-ce qu'on peut faire perdurer la
mémoire et faire en sorte que ça
n'arrive pas
ou plus
que ça n'arrive plus alors là nous a eu
cette chance en effet que que ce
monsieur vive
suffisamment longtemps pour pouvoir
transmettre et témoigner finalement et
je crois que cela vaut plus notamment
auprès d'une jeunesse aujourd'hui qui
est enquête
de connaissances en fin de compréhension
de notre monde et je pense que cela vaut
tous les livres qui peuvent être écrits
sur sur le sujet
après nous avons besoin de ce devoir de
mémoire je vois que par exemple en
Allemagne les Allemands ont travaillé à
cela à la fois pour la Shoah si vous
allez à Berlin vous avez au centre de la
ville
cet espace qui représente un cimetière
qui est dédié justement à ces atrocités
et je pense que chaque pays doit faire
cet exercice alors par le biais bien sûr
des individus qui ont vécu les
événements qui sont en capacité de de
témoigner oralement ou par écrit
et surtout de se dire que chaque guerre
n'apporte que misère désespoir malheurs
et que finalement aujourd'hui dans cette
guerre en Ukraine il faudrait que nous
attachions tous à faire en sorte qu'elle
se termine le plus rapidement possible
et parmi les civils vous savez j'ai vécu
dans un pays en Irlande
où la guerre civile assez VIP pendant
très très longtemps il ne reste que des
marques pendant des générations même
celles qui n'ont pas connu c'est dans le
comment dans la mémoire collective
toutes ces souffrances restent là et
donc il faut faire attention qu'elle a
moindre étincelle et bien on ne ravive
pas le feu et donc il est important d'en
parler il est important de transmettre
en effet toute cette histoire de la
justice puisque Robert hébra a disparu
alors qu'aujourd'hui Marc les 70 ans du
jugement des bourreaux
d'Oradour-sur-Glane
Anne-Sophie vous avez une question
là-dessus sur la justice oui tout à fait
parce que on voit bien la justice et
l'entrée
Robert et brasse a mis beaucoup de temps
avant de parler aujourd'hui sur ces
conflits en Ukraine notamment ou des
massacres ont été perpétrés comment le
la justice fait son travail et combien
de temps faudra-t-il pour que justice
soit faite
vraiment des tribunaux devant un
tribunal international qui en effet fait
son travail peut-être lentement mais qui
le fait et pendant que le comment le
procès est en cours on n'oublie pas je
pense que c'est aussi une façon de se
dire que la justice sera faite un jour
et de ne pas laisser finalement le
désespoir pour les victimes s'installer
parce que il se passe quelque chose en
continuant en parler en continu est-ce
que vous pensez qu'un jour vous l'avez
bien Poutine sera devant les tribunaux
peut-être mais il faut attendre la mort
la fin de la guerre
espérons que elle arrive le plus vite
possible merci beaucoup Anne-Sophie
d'avoir été avec nous vous aussi vous
avez une autre question mais sinon on
regarde votre une
regarde votre une la une du populaire du
centre on a vu celle de ce weekend
évidemment un consacré à Robert et bras
on va regarder celle d'aujourd'hui des
gîtes en format XXL tout autre sujet
c'est à la une du populaire du centre ce
matin merci beaucoup Anne-Sophie d'avoir
été avec nous et merci Hélène fondre
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans
le club des territoires on va parler de
la réforme des retraites nouvelle
journée de mobilisation qui a eu lieu ce
week-end il y en aura une autre jeudi
l'examen du texte qui reprend cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée et ce pour la dernière
semaine on va parler de tout ça et on en
parle tout de suite avec notre prochaine
invité c'est Sylvain Maillard qui nous
rejoint